we're doing something about this
nonsense when it comes to our schools
and our corporations here's Governor Ron
DeSantis and you got a lot of a lot of
Corporations too they're getting
involved in the race game we know
they're already getting involved in the
transgender game you had a little tussle
with Disney is Corporate America on
notice with Ron DeSantis as you get a
little bit of a bigger profile
so my view is is I got to protect the
people of Florida their freedoms and if
woke corporations are threatening their
freedoms then I have to contend with
that and I have to stand up for them so
for example we passed the stop woke act
in Florida that yes banned CRT in the
K-12 schools but it also gave employees
of private corporations the ability to
opt out of this CRT training where
they're basically made to
self-flagellate based on their race we
don't think that that's appropriate so
yes we're willing to step up and support
people's freedoms at the end of the day
you have a right to make your own
decisions live freely without having the
left's agenda crammed down your throat
and whether that's in a school or
whether that's be at the hands of a
multinational corporation we're on your
side not on theirs
Libby isn't this just what we've all
been waiting for for a long time like a
politician to just calmly cleanly say
the truth and help us get out of this
endless bottomless pit that they've
thrown us into
yeah I do think that that's right and
it's interesting that DeSantis takes
this perspective and then from the
federal government you have these
endless pushes of diversity equity and
inclusion executive orders uh the
president just wants to rule by Fiat
from the Oval Office and he's
instructing every single federal agency
to enact additional staff and bring in
all of these extra people to make sure
that the agencies are being compliant
with all of these uh advancing Equity
goals no one really knows what advancing
Equity means except for destroying a
meritocracy and reducing all of our
government agencies and programs to
race-based initiatives that are not fair
that are not um at all egalitarian and
yeah I think that across the country
people appreciate what DeSantis is doing
we saw that with the um parental rights
and education bill which was marvelously
popular across the country no matter how
much the progressive left tried to slam
it as don't say gay which a simple read
of I think was a three-page bill will
show you that it has nothing to do with
that at all the word gay is not in the
bill I was with the governor and the
first lady three days ago showing them
pictures of my kids this thing is so
stupid uh James did you see I feel like
you must have tweeted about this and
maybe I missed it because Twitter's
still so screwy this guy Sam I think
it's Sam Brighton who was the like
assistant secretary to nuclear waste
something or other I don't think he I
don't think he considers himself trans
but I guess he dresses off in like a
woman it's non-binary oh he's okay so
he's non-binary but it turns out that
this guy has been stealing luggage for
years from airports you know when you go
downstairs to get your luggage after the
flight and it now has turned out that in
2018 he stole a bag of luggage from a
black woman and has been wearing her
dresses and posting pictures yeah a
fashion designer nobody so you have a
man and dressing like a woman stealing a
and he's white stealing a black woman's
dresses wearing them and of course he's
Progressive I mean it's like what if
you'd like more sane takes on our insane
World check out our direct message clips
playlist and if you want to watch more
full episodes of our live round tables
watch our round tables playlist they're
both right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell